we can speak now to Kirsty Bisset a
model and friend of reeva Steenkamp it's
been a long-running trial far longer
than its was supposed to be when it
started at Kirsty how do you feel now
that the verdicts are in it's certainly
hasn't been a very very exhausting road
and I think the last two days just
culminated in in so much I I think like
many of Reavers friends and family I'm
feeling extremely devastated by the
verdict and I'm very disappointed I I
personally don't feel that the
punishment has for the crime and you
know I'm no lawyer I can't I can't speak
on behalf of the of our legal system but
I'm personally being very very
disappointed by by the results of the
last two days yeah I mean that the judge
found Oscar Pistorius not guilty of
murder she was very clear in her
explanations as to why she did that she
did find him guilty of culpable homicide
manslaughter as we would call it here is
there part of you that feels relieved
that this phase of this long-running
trial is over well I wouldn't say relief
was the right word there's the whole mix
of emotions going through through many
of us at the moment whether I think more
relief will come once we know what his
sentence is and where we know got
another monkeys actually going to be
punished accordingly in terms of couple
homicide so I think more relief will
coming up so that then today as a friend
how difficult has it been for you to
watch this trial unfolding over the past
few months and to hear those details
about the relationship that Reba had
with Oscar Pistorius but also the very
graphic details about the nature of her
death I thankfully missed out on all of
the graphic detail I managed to she
charged that it's been it's it's still
difficult to refer to Riva in the past
Kings it still doesn't feel real to do
so you know the loss of such such a
beautiful woman and such a close friend
was harrowing it's been
I can't tell you what what we've all
been going through and to see it unfold
on on television on social media and the
papers and it's it's been interesting
and it's been you know a good and a bad
thing because you know in a way she you
know she's been getting her voice heard
you know through who had friends and
family and we've also you know garnered
a lot of insight into into what actually
happened whether we've been told the
truth or not
so it's then it's been a very emotional
few months but you know hopefully we can
all try and move forward from here
tell us about the Reaver that you knew
oh man she I don't think I could tell
you anything that anyone hasn't said
before she was the most exquisite person
one of the most beautiful woman I've
ever known I've known her for and you
heard for about three or four years
prior to her passing you know through
the modeling industry and it was just so
refreshing to know someone like her in
this industry because she she was so
humble she was so funny she was so smart
and of course she was absolutely
beautiful and so you know growing close
to her through through the years was an
absolute honor and to see how successful
she was but how how grounded she still
remained was was a really really
beautiful thing to witness and she just
she was a fantastic place and she you
know you you walked into a room and it
was like her own veins and who fame was
on the rise but she would still run to
you from across the room to come say hi
you know that's just the person that she
was and what did you know about her
relationship with Oscar Pistorius Riva
was generally quite a private person so
I actually wasn't aware of of their
relationship she didn't speak publicly
about it she didn't boast about it or
anything like that
so I was unaware of what was going on
you know behind the scenes and caste I
mean you said you still to this day find
it very difficult to think of Reaver and
speak of her in the past tense
can you take us back to that night to
the 14th of February 2013 when you first
heard the news friendly enough I was
actually in Paris that day yeah Paris on
Valentine's Day it should have been such
an amazing day but yeah I woke up that
morning and I looked at order you know
to see what was going on in the news as
I do and I I saw a tweet from someone
that said that Oscar headshots his
girlfriend and I thought oh my gosh
that's disgusting like he would come up
with such a sick rumor and then it's you
know it became clear through reputable
news sources that that it actually
happened and you know for a second it
kind of went through my mind that you
know I hope that it wasn't her I know
that that sounds so wrong but yeah I
just I was just hoping that it wasn't my
friend you know it just I couldn't
believe what was going on and then when
I found out it was yeah my body reacted
I I was a complete mess the rest of the
day and to to walk through Paris and see
her face on the screen knowing that she
just wasn't there anymore was it was
very surreal and took a very long time
to to sink in you've said I read one of
your blog's
Kirsti where you said that the monks the
circus of this trial and the celebrity
in it sometimes the victim can be
forgotten how would you like people to
remember either she she was just
absolutely exquisite inside and out and
like I said on that very blog those
incidents brought a lot to the fore in
terms of domestic violence in South
Africa and you know if they say that
everything happens for a reason I think
that's that's exactly what Weaver would
have wanted because she was very she
stood very firmly for you know against
gender-based violence and an equality in
South Africa so
I think we can take anything from this
it was it was raising awareness about
that and you know who who passing really
bought 34 and so I'd love people to just
remember her as a wonderful soul a very
kind humble smart soul she was she was
lovely
Kirsty Bassett reeva Steenkamp friend
thank you very much indeed for talking
to us and sharing your memories this
evening